The joe rogan experience.
What did you mean Brian?
Like what were you saying?
No,
I mean it's just like you're saying
about how bad the government is,
how many bad things they've done,
you know,
in the past.
But everyone never looks at the good shit,
you know?
And no one's ever looking at
all the good shit they do.
They're not going to
tell on the bad stuff.
I don't think that's
necessarily the Grand Canyon.
It's bad ass.
Did you ever read watership down?
Government didn't make the grand canyon,
bro Fucking Bust your bubble.
Hey,
will you do me a favor?
I know we're not
plus to play music,
but there's a song that we have to play.
We have to play because I really liked
the song and it's a super appropriate and
we'll just talk over it.
Okay.
We're not like selling it.
It's Aaron Lewis country boy.
You know the dude from stained.
Okay,
well he's reinvented himself as
a country music singer and yes,
yes,
yes.
I want you to think it's important.
It's really important.
It's really important for two reasons.
One because I honestly like this song.
I like the sound a lot.
I really do.
It's a fucking good song
and guys got a great voice.
I loved him and that,
that band stained,
I think he's a bad motherfucker.
He's,
he's got a great voice and a apparel.
It's just so fascinating
because it's a super,
super patriotic song.
Let's hear it.
And it's,
it's so patriotic.
It's like almost like a parody.
Oh,
big toe from the beginning.
From the beginning.
Hit it from the beginning.
Here we go.
Ready?
It's about being a country boy
that's hearing.
We never play songs anymore,
but fuck it man.
I love this song.
No dirt around.
And
how do you know,
do the spin.
Listen how good his voice,
his 1500 bucks back in,
man.
I sound like a home.
I'll put down,
motherfuckers got a bad ass voice.
He could talk me in bed
at night with that voice.
Listen to this
man.
What is,
that's not the h wearing gray.
This is a great fucking song,
Dude.
Rarely drink smoke.
He has.
Don't tread on me.
Tattooed on his neck
tense.
That's intense right across his neck.
It says don't tread on me and this song
is talking about how he never leaves his
house without his nine or is 45
it's like sort of gangster rap.
Tried to know the word
for calm outlaw country.
Damn.
He sold his soul to the devil in La.
This is talking about when
he was in that other band.
Yeah,
set up shop
in fact spinal saying the devil hooked
him up in La with a like a regular guy
check ever see spinal tap.
He's like,
what he's doing is he's making up for
his time as a rockstar now remembering a
spinal tap.
When they sit like that,
there's a great thing where it shows all
the pictures of the band and they tried
every demographic.
They kept changing demographics according
to what was popular and so like he
just swapped demographics,
countries,
publicists and was like,
hey listen.
I think,
I think the country
markets trying to be legit,
just like a gangster rappers trying to
be legit because in the video there's a
picture of him like get to holding a gun.
He's two and he's got a gun in his hand.
I am not bullshitting.
I bill it says me age too.
He's holding a gun and there's another
picture where he's got a large mouth
bass.
See I used a fish,
you know,
so it's like all these pictures of him.
All that shit is like so manipulative
and silly and not whole thing.
Man.
It gets way better.
I grew up on a country in a place,
you never know the last few seconds of it.
I'll tell you Brian,
exactly where to go
because it's so ridiculous.
It was one of my,
it's,
it's just really interesting cause
you know there's a miss hands.
No,
and it's way worse than Mr. Go
to four minutes and 14 seconds.
Go do at a four minutes and 14 seconds.
We'll just end this
because it's fascinating.
By the way,
I'm not dissing this guy at all and
I fucking love this music and I love,
I love his song and I
love that kind of music.
I like it.
A lot of Toby Keith Song,
I don't have anything wrong.
A patriotic songs at the end of it.
Listen,
this guy does this little speech
and this is like this old old dude
that's like,
I love my country.
I love my guns,
my family.
I love the way it is now.
And anybody that tried to change
it has to come through me.
I should be on our end.
It's this isn't America and a country
boy was good enough from Mason.
Okay,
play that back again because that
might be a terrorist message.
Okay.
That retarded fucking speech.
Back it up.
Right
listening,
listening.
Is that a bag?
Listen,
I love my country.
I love my guns,
my family.
I love the way it is now.
And anybody that tried to change
it has to come through me.
That's some music,
our attitude.
That should be all of our answers.
That's,
this is America.
And a contigo is good
enough to make sense.
And she boys getting enough for me like
we are as evolved as I need with stop
right here.
Anybody else talk and he exactly.
If you can listen to a cancer cell,
that's what I sound like.
It's just so fucking stupid.
It's like a little more guns.
Oh,
that's you.
I love my country.
I love guns.
Oh Jesus.
Do just hurry up and die,
but you fucking hurry up you.
He's fucking modeled t human being.
You dip shit.
Just die.
I love my family a lot more guns.
He brought a trash pick
those or they'll come to me.
Let's take a look.
I'm not saying I want to take your guns,
dude.
All right.
I don't want to talk about guns too.
I love my family too.
All right.
Settle the fuck down.
Every time in history,
Christ,
every time in history,
no one's coming through you,
bro.
But every period in history,
he's got those human anchors desperately
trying to dig their claws into the
fucking,
into the earth and keep
evolution from happening.
Desperately fight.
They'll kill for kill for it.
Inquisition.
What do you mean?
Wait a minute.
You can't be serious.
Do you everyone gather around?
Did you hear Galileo?
Did you your what?
Galileo just said,
father,
he said the earth he
speak of not being on top.
I love my earth in the
center of the universe.
My earth.
I love my sticks and he bows and arrows.
I love.
I love birthday years muscling.
I love my slave.
I love my love Vernon,
which is anybody tried
to take my catapult away.
Reebok come through me.
I love my scrawl,
I love them.
I love carving in Rock Hall.
I love walking.
I don't need to ride any horses
need domesticated animals.
That's complicated.
Nobody wants to domesticate.
Horse has got to come through me.
I love being a hunter gatherer.
I love having a lifespan will
be in the single cell organisms.
We all having a good time down here,
the bottom of the ocean floor.
Anybody wants to change that?
We've got to come through me.
I love being a carbon molecule.
I love existed in a pretty big bank.
Conditions.
Hello?
11 protons.
But it was the change that
as open up the second bottle of wine,
it's all like,
no,
no.
I have a question about it.
When you use a beautiful song,
man,
the guy's just sing his fucking ass off.
I'm sorry,
I'm not denying it.
I'm buying that shit on iTunes
right now cause they made funny bro.
I love that song.
No bullshit.
I love,
and he's a Massachusetts boy,
just like,
man,
you're a fucking human being.